- Lemme guess, those are case numbers
from every rape that's
happened in the county?
- State.
- Within the last three years?
- Five.
- Bitch, you are on your game.
(solemn music)
- Unbelievable is a story
about a rape investigation
gone horribly wrong
and then a rape investigation
gone brilliantly right.
- In Marie's case, she got
interviewed several times
and I think it was almost
like she was being attacked
over and over again.
- So basically, you were assaulted twice.
Once by your attacker,
then again by the police.
- Yeah, I guess.
- I am so sorry, Marie.
- It's not your fault.
- It's brave of you to
revisit it, that's not easy.
Thank you for trusting me.
- She just moved into her place
like a couple of months before,
she wakes up in the middle of the night
with this weight on her back,
it's a man on top of her,
pins her arms, tells her he's got a gun,
he's gonna use it if she
gives him any trouble.
- When was this?
- 22nd, about a month ago.
He proceeds to rape her
for three hours on and off.
I mean.
- Same thing with my victim.
Stopping and starting for four hours.
- Huh.
(solemn music)
- We felt a great deal of responsibility
in telling this story.
One case where there was a
real miscarriage of justice
and one case where two cops,
who happened to be women,
got it right and ultimately,
their good work changes the life of Marie.